nothing in the universe is static
in the milky way billions of stars orbit
the galactic centre some like our sun
are pretty consistent keeping a distance
of around 30 000 light years from the
galactic centre completing an orbit
every 230 million years
this dance is not an orderly ballet more
like a skating rink filled with drunk
toddlers
this chaos makes the galaxy dangerous
our solar neighborhood is constantly
changing with stars moving hundreds of
kilometers every second
only the vast distances between objects
protect us from the dangers out there
but we might get unlucky in the future
at some point we can encounter a star
going supernova
or a massive object passing by and
showering earth with asteroids
if something like this were to happen we
would likely know thousands if not
millions of years in advance
but we still couldn't do much about it
unless we move our whole solar system
out of the way
[Music]
to move the solar system we need a
stellar engine a mega structure used to
steer a star through the galaxy it's the
kind of thing that might be built by an
advanced civilization with dyson sphere
level technology that's thinking about
their future millions of years ahead of
time
but how do we possibly move the hundreds
of thousands of objects in the solar
system
the good news is we can ignore all of
that
we only need to move the sun all the
other stuff is glued to it by gravity
and will follow it wherever it decides
to go
there are lots of ideas about what a
stellar engine might look like and how
it would work
we've picked two grounded in our current
understanding of physics that could be
built in theory
the simplest kind of stellar engine is
the shut off thruster a giant mirror
it works on the same principle as a
rocket
like rocket fuel the photons released as
solar radiation carry momentum
not a lot but a bit
for example if an astronaut turned on a
flashlight in space it would push them
backwards very very slowly
a stellar engine will work a little
better than a flashlight because the sun
produces a lot of photons
the basic idea of the shut-off thruster
is to reflect up to half of the solar
radiation to create thrust and slowly
push the sun where we want it to go
in order for the shkadov thruster to
work it must be kept in the same place
not orbiting the sun
although the sun's gravity will try to
pull it in it would be supported by
radiation pressure which props the
mirror up
this means the mirror would have to be
very light made of micron thin
reflecting foil from materials like
aluminium alloys
the mirror's shape is important too
enveloping the sun in a giant spherical
shell wouldn't work because that would
refocus light back to the sun heating it
up and creating all sorts of unpleasant
problems
instead we use a parabola which sends
most of the photons around the sun and
in the same direction which maximizes
thrust
to prevent accidentally burning or
freezing earth with too much or too
little sunlight the only safe place to
build a shkadov thruster is over the
sun's poles this means we can only move
the sun vertically in the plane of the
solar system and one direction in the
milky way which limits our travel
options a bit
but that is basically it
for a civilization capable of building a
dyson sphere this is a relatively simple
endeavor
not complicated just very hard to build
at full throttle the solar system could
probably be moved by about a hundred
light years over 230 million years
over a few billion years it gives us
near complete control over the sun's
orbit in the galaxy
but in the short term this might not be
fast enough to dodge a deadly supernova
that's why we thought we could do better
so we asked our astrophysicist friend if
he could design a faster stellar engine
for this video
he did and wrote a paper about it that's
been published in a peer-reviewed
journal
you can find it in our sources document
we're going to call our new stellar
engine the kaplan thruster
it works a lot like a traditional rocket
shoot exhaust one way to push yourself
the other
it's a large space station platform
powered by a dyson sphere that gathers
matter from the sun to power nuclear
fusion
it shoots out a very fast jet of
particles at nearly one percent the
speed of light out of the solar system
a second jet pushes the sun along like a
tugboat
the kaplan thruster requires a lot of
fuel millions of tons per second
to gather this fuel our thruster uses
very large electromagnetic fields to
funnel hydrogen and helium from the
solar wind into the engine
the solar wind alone doesn't provide
enough fuel though and that's where the
dyson sphere comes in
using its power sunlight can be
refocused to the surface of the sun
this heats small regions to extreme
temperatures lifting billions of tons of
mass off the sun
this mass can be collected and separated
into hydrogen and helium
the helium is burned explosively in
thermonuclear fusion reactors
a jet of radioactive oxygen at a
temperature of nearly a billion degrees
is expelled and becomes our primary
source of propulsion from our stellar
engine
to prevent the engine from just crashing
into the sun it needs to balance itself
to do this we accelerate the collected
hydrogen with electromagnetic fields
using particle accelerators and shoot a
jet back at the sun
this balances the thruster and transfers
the thrust of our engine back to the sun
in as little as a million years this
engine can move the sun by 50 light
years more than enough to dodge a
supernova
at full throttle the solar system can be
completely redirected in its galactic
orbit in 10 million years
but wait won't we use up the sun this
way
fortunately the sun is so massive that
even billions of tons of material will
barely scratch the surface in fact this
megastructure will actually extend our
sun's life since lower mass stars burn
slower keeping the solar system
inhabitable for many more billions of
years
with a kaplan thruster we could turn the
entire solar system into our spaceship
for example by orbiting backwards in the
galaxy and colonizing hundreds or
thousands of stars as we pass by them
it may even be possible to escape the
galaxy entirely and expand beyond the
milky way
stellar engines are the kind of machines
built by civilizations thinking not in
terms of years or decades but eons
since we know that our sun will die one
day a stellar engine could allow the far
future descendants of humans to travel
to other stars without ever having to
venture into the terrifying dark abyss
of interstellar space
until we build a stellar engine we're
adrift and subject to the whims of the
galactic sea
we may not like where it leads us
maybe our descendants will set sail and
become an interstellar species for
millions of years to come
this was our last video for the year
12019 of the human era and what a year
it was
so much stuff happened everywhere to so
many different people
calendars and holidays are just
imaginary but they help us to cut our
lives into pieces that our brains can
handle
we're leaving 12019 behind with a weird
mixture of disillusion and hope
the world is screwed up but we can fix
it in a few days this year will be over
and we all get to try again
thank you for watching our videos and
for sticking around for so many years
see you all in 12020
[Music]
shhh
you